بدايه تحرك قوات من اوكرانيا نحو العمق
الروسي كانت باتجاه روستو وهي احدى اكبر
المدن الروسيه وتعد عاصمه الجنوب الروسي
المجاور لاجزاء من شرق اوكرانيا حيث تدور
رحل الحرب
تستضيف هذه المقاطعه مركز قياده المنطقه
العسكريه الروسيه الجنوبيه وهي مركز
لوجستي مهم للجيش الروسي ونظرا لمرور
الطريق السريع المسمى ام 4 وهو شريان
المواصلات الذي يربط شمال روسيا بجنوبها
ومنطقه شمال القوقاز فقد سلكت قوات فاجنر
هذا الطريق ووصلت بحسب قولها الى مدينه
بورونيج الواقعه على بعد ثلاثمائه كيلومتر
الى الشمال من روستو علما ان مدينه
فورونيج تقع في منتصف الطريق بين روستوف
والعاصمه موسكو التي تقول قوه فاجنر انها
تتجه اليها تحت مسمى مسيره العداله